die Pille wird dieses Jahr 60 Jahre alt
1961 kam sie in Deutschland auf den
Markt und war eine riesen Kontroverse
ich lehne die Pille für junge Mädchen ab
sie automatisiert die Liebe und versaut
die Murat gleichzeitig war sie ein
gamechanger ein Meilenstein für die
weibliche Selbstbestimmung und sexuelle
Freiheit doch ihre Beliebtheit ist jetzt
seit Jahren rückläufig ich habe meine
Pille abgesetzt ich dachte wie krass ist
das denn und das war tatsächlich der
erste Moment wo mir so richtig bewusst
geworden ist dass das Pille nehmen
vielleicht gar nicht so eine gute Idee
ist also ich habe die Pille vor einiger
Zeit abgesetzt weil sich die
Nebenwirkungen einfach so gehäuft haben
dass es zu unangenehm wurde klar Risiken
und Nebenwirkungen gibt es bei allen
Medikamenten aber sind sie bei der Pille
verhältnismäßig und was ist mit der
Pille für den Mann hier hat man oft von
einer klinischen Studie die wegen
Nebenwirkungen abgebrochen wurde
Nebenwirkungen die bei der Pille für die
Frau allerdings akzeptiert werden auch
das wollen wir uns heute genauer
anschauen außerdem hört man immer wieder
die Pille würde heute gar nicht mehr die
Zulassung bekommen wie muss man das
verstehen wir haben also einiges vor
holt euch ein Tee macht es euch
gemütlich wir steigen durch
[Musik]
so um zu verstehen wie die Antibabypille
wirkt müssen wir erstmal verstehen wie
der Menstruationszyklus funktioniert der
Menstruationszyklus in den Eierstöcken
liegen die Eizellen umgeben von Hüllen
die man Follikel nennt im Gehirn wird
das Follikel stimulierende Hormon kurz
FSH ausgeschüttet der Name ist Programm
das Hormon stimuliert die Follikel die
reifen heran und produzieren das Hormon
Östrogen wir steigen der Östrogenspiegel
führt zum Aufbau der
Gebärmutterschleimhaut dieses gut
durchblutete gewebekissen ist notwendig
damit sich eine Eizelle im Falle einer
Befruchtung gut in der Gebärmutter
einnisten kann wenn der Östrogenspiegel
einen gewissen Wert erreicht wird ein
weiteres Hormon ausgeschüttet LH steht
für luteinisierendes Hormon LH löst den
Eisprung aus Eisprung heißt die Eizelle
verlässt ihren Follikel und macht sich
auf den Weg durch den Eileiter in die
Gebärmutter und hier sind wir jetzt in
einem Zeitfenster von fünf bis 24
Stunden in dem die Eizelle befruchtet
werden kann doch nicht nur während
dieses Zeitfensters kann Sex zu
Schwangerschaft führen sondern auch bis
zu fünf Tage vorher weil Spermien so
lange überleben und auf ihren Einsatz
warten können der nach dem Eisprung
zurückbleibende Follikel wird zum
sogenannten Gelbkörper der Gelbkörper
hält einen gewissen Östrogenspiegel
aufrecht und schüttet noch ein weiteres
Hormon aus Progesteron Progesteron und
Östrogen gemeinsam hemmen nun die
Ausschüttung der Hormone FSH und LH in
dieser Phase des Zyklus gibt es keine
weitere Follikelreifung nach ca 14 Tagen
bildet sich der Gelbkörper zurück und
hört auf Hormone auszuschütten heißt
Östrogen und Progesteronspiegel fallen
ab es kommt zur Abstoßung der
aufgebauten Gebärmutterschleimhaut
sprich zur Menstruation denn ohne eine
befruchtete Eizelle braucht man dieses
Kissen zum einnisten ja nicht mehr und
dann geht der ganze Zyklus wieder von
vorne so wenn man jetzt die
Antibabypille nimmt passiert folgendes
wie die Antibabypille wirkt die
klassische Antibabypille enthält zwei
Substanzen erstens ein Östrogen und zwar
den allermeisten Fällen das
östrogenetinyl Estradiol 2 ein Gestagen
hier gibt es unterschiedliche Arten von
gestern die zum Einsatz kommen je nach
Präparat diese Gestagene wirken wie das
körpereigene Progesteron das ebenfalls
zur hormonfamilie der Gestagene gehört
solange die Pille eingenommen wird haben
wir eine Situation wie hier die Kombi
aus Östrogen und Gäste gehen hemmt die
Ausschüttung der Hormone FSH und LH das
heißt die Situation die normalerweise
während der zweiten Hälfte des Zyklus
vorliegt herrscht jetzt durchgängig
solange man die Pille nimmt genau
genommen passieren drei Dinge erstens
die Reifung der Follikel und der
Eisprung werden verhindert zweitens die
Gebärmutterschleimhaut wird nicht
gescheit aufgebaut so dass ich eine
Eizelle da auch nicht richtig einnisten
könnte und
das gestern sorgt dafür dass der
Muttermund der diktier durchgängig mit
einem dicken Schleimpfropfen verstopft
ist so dass Spermien da nicht
durchkommen den gibt es normalerweise
auch aber während eines normalen Zyklus
wird dieser Pfropfen während der
fruchtbaren Tage dünn und durchlässig
und genau das wird eben durch die Pille
auch unterbunden die Pille hat also eine
dreifachwirkung gegen Schwangerschaft
aber was genau ist die Pille unter der
Pille versteht man normalerweise das
eben beschriebene Kombipräparat aus
Östrogen und gestern gehen doch diese
kombipille hat sich in den 60 Jahren in
denen sie jetzt gibt auch
weiterentwickelt und heute gibt es
dutzende verschiedene Antibabypillen die
sich in Zusammensetzung und
Konzentration unterscheiden mit dem Ziel
Nebenwirkungen zu reduzieren darauf
gehen wir auch gleich noch genauer ein
wurde der Östrogengehalt immer weiter
reduziert ab einer östrogenmenge von 50
Mikrogramm oder weniger pro Pille
spricht man von einer Mikropille nur ist
der Begriff Mikropille eigentlich
hinfällig geworden weil es heute kaum
noch Pillen gibt die einen
Östrogengehalt von über 50 Mikrogramm
haben das heißt die Mikropille ist die
Pille von heute außerdem unterscheiden
sich Pillen wie gesagt auch in der Art
der eingesetzten gestern Gene und dann
gibt es noch die Mini-Pille die
Minipille enthält gar kein Östrogen
sondern nur gestern die Minipille ist
also ein sogenanntes mono-präparat kein
Kombi Präparat aber die go-to-pille also
die Pille ist das Kombipräparat aus
Östrogen und Gäste gehen das ist also
auch die Pille über die wir hier
sprechen und ja diese Nomenklatur mit
minipellonikropille ist sehr verwirrend
deswegen gut dass wir das jetzt mal
geklärt haben wie gut verhütet die Pille
die Wirksamkeit einer Verhütungsmethode
wird oft mit dem sogenannten Pearl-Index
angegeben der Pearl-Index besagt wenn
100 Frauen ein Jahr lang mit einer
bestimmten Methode verhüten
wie viele von ihnen werden trotzdem
schwanger wenn sehen von hundert Frauen
schwanger werden dann ist der
Pearl-Index 10 wenn es zwei von 100 sind
dann ist der Pearl-Index 2 Kondome zum
Beispiel haben ein Pearl-Index von 2 bei
Perfect use also bei perfekt korrekter
Nutzung in der Praxis kommt man nur auf
einen Pearl-Index von 18 die Pille hat
bei Perfect use also unter
Optimalbedingungen einen Pearl-Index von
0,3 also ziemlich niedrig in der Praxis
allerdings nur einen von neun wenn man
zum Beispiel Durchfall hat oder sich
übergibt dann können die Hormone im
Zweifelsfall nicht richtig aufgenommen
werden oder man vergisst eine Einnahme
einer Pille gerade wenn das am Anfang
des Zyklus passiert dann ist trotzdem
zum eisprungkopf deswegen korrekte
Anwendung ist essentiell für eine
wirksame Verhütung trotzdem zählt die
Pille im Vergleich zu den wirksamsten
Verhütungsmethoden aber was ist mit den
Nebenwirkungen zu Risiken und Wirkungen
lesen Sie die Packungsbeilage ich lasse
es hier mal ein bisschen laufen da
findet man nämlich einiges das
überrascht euch erstmal nicht denn
Hormone haben nie nur eine bestimmte
Funktion sondern sind immer
multifunktional und sehr komplex und
obwohl diese Nebenwirkungen in
wissenschaftlichen Studien beobachtet
werden ist es schwer vorauszusagen mit
welchem
Nebenwirkungsprofil man persönlich
rechnen muss in der Praxis also in der
Frauenarztpraxis wird das passendste
Präparat für eine individuelle Person
meist eher auf Basis von Erfahrung oder
trial und era ausgesucht was aus
wissenschaftlicher Sicht natürlich sehr
unbefriedigend ist doch die
Erfahrungsberichte sind nun einmal sehr
individuell also wenn ich die Pille
nehme dann werde ich zur Furie starke
Stimmungsschwankungen also bei mir ging
es wirklich so wegen diesem kleinen
bisschen geheult manche nehmen zu manche
nehmen ab total zugenommen
beziehungsweise hat sich Wasser
angelagert für mich war das was sehr
schönes das heißt die Brüste sind
gewachsen POS gewachsen und zwar hatte
ich zum Beispiel Appetitlosigkeit und
dadurch habe ich natürlich weniger
gegessen habe abgenommen
passender Lust auf Sex ein ganz massiven
libido-verlust die Pille erhöht das
Risiko für Thrombose sondern das ist
kreuzgefährlich ich selber habe aufgrund
der Einnahme einer risikoreicheren
Antibabypille eine beidseitige
Lungenembolie erlitten mit akuten atmen
und Herzstillstand und war dann auch
klinisch tot und konnte nur durch eine
schwierige und komplizierte Notoperation
gerettet werden das erhöhte
Thrombose-Risiko ist die wohl schwerste
Nebenwirkung da sie tödlich enden kann
und in jeder Packungsbeilage gibt es für
Thrombosen bzw Blutgerinnsel einen
extra-abschnitt zusätzlich zu den
Nebenwirkungen deswegen schauen wir uns
das mal genauer an von einer Thrombose
spricht man wenn Blut im Körper zu
Klumpen gerinnt dieser Verklumpungen
nennt man trompen es gibt venöse
Thrombosen und arterielle Thrombosen je
nachdem ob die trompen in Venen oder
Arterien entstehen die Venen führen das
Blut zum Herzen hin die Arterien vom
Herz Weg normalerweise soll Blut nur in
Wunden gerinnen um die zu verschließen
wenn das im Körper passiert ist sowieso
schon mal nicht gut besonders gefährlich
wird es aber wenn die trompen vom Blut
wieder mitgerissen werden und woanders
Gefäße verstopfen das nennt man dann
Thromboembolie für Frauen im
gebärfähigen Alter die keine Pille
nehmen liegt das Risiko für venöse
thrombo Embolie bei zwei von 10.000
Frauen pro Jahr mit der Pille erhöht
sich das Risiko auf 5 bis 7 von 10.000
Frauen pro Jahr es ist also absolut
gesehen immer noch eine seltene
Nebenwirkung aber im Vergleich zu keiner
Pille etwa eine Verdreifachung des
Risikos schuld daran ist in erster Linie
das Östrogen je niedriger der
Östrogengehalt einer Pille desto
niedriger das Thromboserisiko die
Mini-Pille zum Beispiel die gar kein
Östrogenen hält hat auch kein erhöhtes
Thromboserisiko dafür aber andere
Nebenwirkungen und trotzdem wirken sich
auch die Gestagene auf das
Thrombose-Risiko in den Kombipräparaten
aus die Kombipräparate mit diesen
Gestagenen haben das geringste
Thrombose-Risiko man spricht hier
manchmal auch von den Pillen der zweiten
Generation die Pillen der dritten oder
vierten Generation also neuere Präparate
die diese Gestagene enthalten haben ein
höheres Thrombose-Risiko hier gilt also
nicht je neuer desto besser falls sie
die Pille nimmt könnt ihr hier ja noch
mal gegenchecken was für eine ihr habt
es gilt die ich sag mal allgemeine
Empfehlung wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt
mit der Pille anfängt dass man eines der
Präparate mit dem niedrigsten
Thrombose-Risiko nimmt viele haben
leider den Eindruck dass ihnen
irgendeine random Pille verschrieben
wurde und fühlen sich nicht ausreichend
informiert da redet niemand in der
Schule drüber why you know talking und
das heißt deine Frauenärztin hat sich
überhaupt nicht informiert was die
Nebenwirkungen angeht
besser aufklären denn ganz viel hat man
uns Frauen einfach nie gesagt es stand
nie irgendwas anders im Raum das war
einfach klar okay gut dann hast Du hier
ein Rezept für die Pille Punkt doch die
naheliegende Frage ist jetzt natürlich
warum wird überhaupt irgendetwas anderes
als das hier verschrieben warum gibt es
überhaupt noch andere Pillen auf dem
Markt mit höherem Thrombose-Risiko ja
dafür gibt es unterschiedliche Gründe
erstmal geht die Wirkung der Pille ja
über die Verhütung hinaus manchen Frauen
hilft die Pille bei starken
Menstruationsbeschwerden zum Beispiel
wenn man sehr starke Schmerzen hat die
Pille wird auch manchmal gegen starke
Körperbehaarung oder starke Akne
verschrieben und solche Anwendungen ich
finde die geben schon ein
problematischen Anreiz also ich finde es
deswegen umso wichtiger gerade junge
Frauen sehr sehr sorgfältig aufzuklären
und zu informieren denn als ich keine
Ahnung 16 war hätte ich hätte ich alles
für eine bessere Haut gemacht scheiß auf
die Packungsbeilage deswegen muss man
echt aufpassen und zurück zu den
unterschiedlichen Präparaten es gibt ja
auch auch andere Nebenwirkungen außer
Thromboserisiko und Frauen haben
offenbar sehr individuelle Erfahrungen
damit und für manche Frauen mag eine
Pille mit niedrigerem Thromboserisiko
insgesamt schlechter verträglich sein
wenn andere Nebenwirkungen dafür umso
stärker reinhauen wir sind jetzt aber
bei einem der größten Streitthemen beim
Thema Pille die Initiative risikopille
zum Beispiel eine Initiative Thrombose
Geschädigter fordert unter anderem den
Verkaufsstopp von Pillen mit höherem
riesige Potenzial für Thrombosen und
Schlaganfälle mehr Gedanken dazu gibt es
im letzten Kapitel dieses Videos aber
warum müssen sich eigentlich nur Frauen
damit rumschlagen warum keine Pille für
den Mann es gibt einen Ansatz für die
Pille für den Mann oder für die Pille
denn es wird am Ende wahrscheinlich
keine Pille sein sondern entweder ein
Gel dass man sich zum Beispiel täglich
auf den Oberarm schmiert oder eine
Spritze die man sich alle paar Wochen
bis Monate in zum Beispiel Oberschenkel
gibt das Grundprinzip wäre aber ähnlich
nämlich eine hormonelle Verhütung die
für die Dauer der Einnahme in das
Fortpflanzungssystem eingreift aber auch
wieder back to Normen geht wenn man mit
der Einnahme aufhört das Ziel bei der
Pille würde man ist es die
Spermienanzahl weit genug runter zu
fahren nämlich auf unter eine Million
Spermien pro Milliliter Sperma was immer
noch sehr viel klingt aber nicht mehr
ausreicht für eine Schwangerschaft 2016
gab es jetzt aber Schlagzeilen eine
klinische Studie mit 320 Männern die
eine solche Verhütungsspritze testeten
wurde vorzeitig abgebrochen wegen der
Nebenwirkungen dabei waren die
Nebenwirkungen für gleichbar mit denen
die auch in der Packungsbeilage der
Antibabypille stehen wenn nicht sogar
insgesamt weniger schwerwiegend es waren
dabei Stimmungsschwankungen
Veränderungen der Libido Hautprobleme
schmerzende Einstichstelle es waren
insgesamt nur sehr wenige Fälle als
schwere nebenwir kategorisiert 91% der
Nebenwirkungen wurden als mild 99% als
moderat festgehalten das löste bei
einigen Unverständnis bis hin zu Wut aus
ach so wir Frauen sollen seit 60 Jahren
mit den Nebenwirkungen klarkommen aber
für Männer ist es zu viel verlangt oder
wie also erstmal der Studienabbruch war
tatsächlich nicht so leicht
nachvollziehbar es war eine
internationale Studie mit zehn
Testzentren in unterschiedlichen Ländern
und wenn man genau hinschaut gab es
auffällige Häufungen in einem dieser
zehnte Zentren nämlich in dem in
Indonesien zum Beispiel wurden 62 der 65
gemeldete psychischen Beschwerden in
Indonesien aufgenommen auch 67 Prozent
der Schmerzen an der Einstichstelle und
91% der Muskelschmerzen sind diesem
einen Testzentrum Indonesien zu sorgen
wie gesagt von insgesamt 10 das heißt
bei den restlichen neuen testszentren
waren die Nebenwirkungen insgesamt
deutlich niedriger also mir sieht es
eher danach aus als sei dieses eine
irgendeine Art von Ausreißer vielleicht
wurden die Nebenwirkungen dort anders zu
Protokoll genommen oder vielleicht gab
es irgendeine Besonderheit mit den
Probanden vor Ort außerdem gab es zwei
unterschiedliche Ethikkommissionen also
die Ethik Leute in solchen klinischen
Studien sind unter anderem dafür
zuständig zu beurteilen wann
Nebenwirkungen noch angemessen sind oder
nicht eine Ethikkommission kam zu dem
Schluss das alles in Ordnung ist die
andere war aber der Meinung diese Studie
muss abgebrochen werden also es war auch
nicht eindeutig es ist also nicht fair
aus diesem Studienabbruch die
Schlussfolgerung zu ziehen dass das
Problem an
heulenden Männern liegt die keine
Nebenwirkungen akzeptieren können und
alles auf uns Frauen schieben wollen im
Gegenteil die allermeisten Männer dieser
Studie hatten kein Problem mit den
Nebenwirkungen war alles cool für die
und nur fünf Prozent gaben an dass sie
diese Methode nicht anwenden wollen
deckt sich übrigens auch mit Aussagen
aus anderen Studien für mich sieht es so
aus dabei die Akzeptanz bei Männern für
die Pille für den Mann viel höher als es
in vielen öffentlichen Diskussionen
erscheint
unbedingt die Forschung geht auch noch
weiter aber letztendlich der Ansatz ist
da die Nachfrage ist da
[Musik]
jetzt jetzt mach doch mal bitte nicht
hormonelle Verhütungsmethoden wenn du
also darüber nachdenkt was gibt es denn
noch so an Verhütung dass nicht auf
Hormon basiert fällt den meisten erstmal
nur das Kondom rein aber es gibt
natürlich noch mehr wenn man als Mann
keine Kinder haben möchte oder keine
Kinder mehr haben möchte ist eine
Vasektomie eine einfache und risikoarme
Option nur nicht so ohne weiteres
reversibel es wird aber auch an
reversiblen Methoden gearbeitet und
geforscht zum Beispiel an einem Gel das
den Samenleiter verstießt und das bei
Bedarf auch wieder rausgespült werden
kann bei Frauen ist eine vielleicht
unterschätzte Methode die sogenannte
natürliche Familienplanung hier bestimmt
man seine fruchtbaren Tage indem man
Körpertemperatur und Zervixschleim
beobachtet ihr erinnert euch an diesen
Schleimpfropfen der Schleim wird während
der fruchtbaren Tage ersichtlich
dünnflüssiger mehr Infos dazu in der
Videobeschreibung der Pearl-Index der
natürlichen Familienplanung ist bei
korrekter Anwendung also per News 0,6
und im Real Life 1,8 nicht zu
verwechseln mit der Kalendermethode wo
man einfach nur seinen Zyklus trackt und
dann die fruchtbaren Tage ausrechnet das
ist ziemlich unsicher würde die Pille
heute noch zugelassen werden man hört
immer wieder dass die Pille heute nicht
mehr zugelassen werden würde was viele
unter diesem Satz verstehen ist sowas
wie die Pille dürfte eigentlich gar
nicht da sein die hätte nie zugelassen
werden sollen oder die Nebenwirkungen
sind so schlimm dass die heute damit
nicht mehr durchkommen würden aber weil
die halt schon da ist
haben die Hersteller Glück gehabt und
wir Frauen Pech so ist es aber nicht ein
Medikament das jetzt auf Markt ist und
nach aktuellen oder aktualisierten
Sicherheitsstandards so schwere
nehmenwirkungen hat dass eine
Neuzulassung daran scheitern würde würde
natürlich auch wieder vom Markt genommen
werden oder entsprechend eingeschränkt
werden ganz falsch ist der Satz
allerdings auch nicht weil zum Beispiel
eine neue Pille die dieselben
Nebenwirkungen hätte wie die
ursprünglichen Pillen die der ersten
Generation jetzt heute ist tatsächlich
nicht mehr auf den Markt schaffen würden
weil es ja inzwischen andere Präparate
mit besserem Risiko nutzenverhältnis
gibt allgemeiner gesagt ob ein
Medikament zugelassen wird hängt auch
von den verfügbaren Alternativen ab
deswegen lenkt die Frage würde die Pille
heute noch zugelassen werden eigentlich
so bisschen vom Kern ab die relevante
Frage ist sind die Nebenwirkungen der
Pille an Essen die Diskussion darüber
wird oft sehr emotional geführt was ich
gut nachvollziehen kann weil eine
objektive Beantwortung nicht ganz
einfach ist aber es gibt drei Begriffe
die helfen können das Ganze zu
versachlichen Wirksamkeit nutzen und
Notwendigkeit alle drei Kriterien sind
bei einem Medikament oder einer
medizinischen Maßnahme wichtig doch
meistens reden wir nur über Wirksamkeit
es steht zwar an erster Stelle ohne
Wirksamkeit keinen Nutzen und ohne
Nutzen keine Notwendigkeit aber ein
wirksames Medikament hat nicht
automatisch eine nutzen und was nutzen
hat ist nicht automatisch notwendig also
lasst einmal durchsteigen unter
Wirksamkeit versteht man die
medizinische pharmakologische Wirkung
also bei der Pille ist es die Verhütung
aber auch Hilfe gegen
Menstruationsbeschwerden dazu zählen
aber auch die Nebenwirkungen und allein
die Abwägung Wirkung versus
Nebenwirkungen ist von Mensch zu Mensch
und von Präparat zu Präparat
unterschiedlich zu nutzen zählen Dinge
wie eine verbesserte Qualität oder im
Fall der Pille sexuelle Freiheit und ihr
seht hoffentlich schon sowas wie
objektiven oder allgemeingültigen nutzen
gibt es nicht nutzen ist etwas sehr
subjektives und individuelles
Notwendigkeit bei einer medizinischen
Maßnahme spricht man von Notwendigkeit
wenn zwei Dinge gegeben sind 1 wenn der
Nutzen der Maßnahme ausreichend groß ist
und zweitens wenn es für diese Maßnahme
keine Alternative gibt sich darüber
Gedanken zu machen ist nicht nur sehr
hilfreich für die persönliche
Entscheidung soll ich die Pille nehmen
oder nicht oder auch für die Diskussion
darüber welche Nebenwirkungen vertretbar
sind sondern zum Beispiel auch für die
Diskussion um die Pille für den Mann was
meint ihr gibt es eine Notwendigkeit für
die Pille für den Mann manche würden
sagen
wäre vielleicht schön wenn es gibt aber
von Notwendigkeit kann man nicht
sprechen denn es gibt ja die Pille für
die Frau ich persönlich würde eher sagen
doch es gibt die Notwendigkeit denn es
gibt ja keinen anderes hormonelles
Verhütungsmittel für den Mann aber das
ist jetzt eine meinungssache ne das ist
keine wissenschaftliche Frage mehr also
ihr seht bei der Pille geht es nicht nur
um Wirksamkeit und Nebenwirkungen
sondern auch um nutzen und Notwendigkeit
und da kann man keine allgemeingültigen
Schlüsse ziehen das ist vielleicht auch
der Grund warum bei diesem Thema so
heftig gestritten wird aber dann lasst
doch versuchen das hier in den
Kommentaren ein bisschen konstruktiver
und sachlicher zu machen und zwar wenn
ihr Erfahrungen mit der Pille habt und
sie teilen möchtet dann teilt doch nicht
nur eure
wirksamkeitserfahrung also Wirkung und
Nebenwirkungen vor allem sondern teilt
uns doch auch mit wie ihr persönlich
nutzen und Notwendigkeit beurteilt finde
ich sehr spannend in der endcard
verlinke ich euch ein Video von unseren
Funkkollegen von der Fall und zwar
handelt es sich hier um einer jungen
Frau die durch die Antibabypille eine
lebensgefährliche Lungenembolie erlitten
hat und gerichtlich gegen den Hersteller
Bayer kämpft und von uns von mylab noch
ein Video über Antidepressiva wir sehen
uns bald und bis dahin bleibt sicher